c'était un coaching pour savoir comment
mener campagne comment répond non c'est
pas ne s'est pas de coaching je pense
pas que ce soit dans son rôle d'ailleurs
de faire du coaching c'était plutôt de
la pédagogie sur les mesures
gouvernementales
voilà nous expliquer bien la cohérence
nous rappeler la cohérence qui était qui
et celle du trou dans des républiques
qui l'avait annoncé lors de la
conférence nationale les territoires le
17 juillet dernier pour une remise en
perspective le dire un peu voilà quelle
va être la feuille de route des
premières semaines de prochaines
semaines et des premiers mois voilà
pourquoi il faut qu'on ait une vision
globale de ce que veut faire le
gouvernement leur philippe on est un
pays en marche